now Elizabeth and Jennifer you've never
been before no there's so many people
what's cold outside you're the lone
Brits flying the flag so I'll do it try
to do what I mean you should keep
talking though because Elizabeth you
really like the English accent aye yes
that's that is true III think the
English accent is rather sexy yeah yeah
yeah I feel like if you read the
phonebook to me in a British accent it's
coming off don't you do you live with
Paul I do but Bernie he finds things
funny that you don't understand him
finding funny yeah well you know we
speak the same language but the words
have different meanings you know like
for example my family a lot of that
people my family my cousins are in the
garment business and they make they make
khaki pants you know it's like their big
staple of their industries there's my
husband things is just hysterical it is
quite funny you should wash your khaki
pants
[Applause]
to watch the cocky pants though you're
cocky pain I heard something that you
guys think is funny is you've ever heard
of Kenny Rogers roosters the yeah the
the chickens yeah that's pretty funny
right Kenny Rogers roosters oh I get it
yeah go on the show and say this
really killed wedge
[Music]
you